this question that we're looking at is
number 11 in exercise 70 70 70 okay so
the question says if you have it there
in fact I'm pretty much sure I remember
everything Provost its unit circle it's
a unit circle and you have a particle
object or a point and it's doing this it
is moving in an anti-clockwise direction
and i believe the speed they give you is
soo m/s around the circumference okay so
this is thing is moving around around
around around they say this is the unit
circle but because we're dealing with
m/s they say okay let's put some unit
honest so they call that one meter
you've got one betta up here and I guess
this would be negative 1 meters ? anyway
we're not dealing with you to 10 we're
dealing with actually meters that's
quite a kabhi so then the question
becomes if we consider the particle just
on the top half of the circle if you
want to think about the bottom half
you're seeing a better it ends up being
exactly said big but in Reverse if the
particle would just think about on the
top purpose of the circle or the top
semicircle what is the particles rate of
change horizontally how is exchanging as
this guy moves around and around the
circle okay in fact the exact wedding
says find an expression for the rate of
change of its x-coordinate i'm going to
call this some a perfect points i'm
going to 4p find expression for the rate
of change off its x-coordinate in terms
of X when the point is above the x-axis
so that's this tops a vehicle like I was
saying so this thing is moving how does
it mean so this is a tricky question
there are lots of parts to it it's
deceptively simple to set up is
deceptively simple I want to read a
change for the x-coordinate right so and
it's with respect to time so where am i
headed watch my last line babe what
actual variable in my after i went to x
of duty
that's okay so Jeff it's crazy what is
it the fun oh thanks Tom we're worried
um now then 1dx ODT that's what I'm
after right how is exchanging with
respect to time so let's just write that
down for a second I want DX on duty this
is um this is my goal this is where I'm
headed okay now as we looked at with the
sand pile it was growing right you have
your goal but this is like the available
fish we've got is actually quite far
removed from this okay they've taught us
and I put it here in the diagram that
it's moving im sue m/s around the
circumference now this is not a
horizontal move motion or operations
some combination of us and it's actually
changing direction all the way around so
the question is what actual derivative
what quantity do I have what does this
number two what's it equal to in this
situation now I'll give you notes for a
second the pilot probably is that we
don't really have when we lack the
notation and we like the labels to
really talk in a concrete rigorous way
about what is actually changing like
what is the UM I think we all know it's
D something on dt right something is
changing with respect to time it's
meters per second but the question is
what is the theme that's changing any
takers well you record what he thinks is
Sanjay okay so you're talking about like
a the fact that it's changing direction
all the way around so if I drew and this
is actually not going to help us but I
want to start the stable work round so
here if I draw a tangent here right at
that particular instant of time that's
the direction the particles moving yeah
and if I'd your attention here at that
particular instant in time that's where
the particles moving now the reason why
I'm going to understand that but abandon
it is because this
this is like Lords ingredient isn't it
but this is a distance so grating is
changing but it's not this this is not
what that is talking about um Nikita
you're never sure okay arc length how
about arc length can we go with this now
probably for me is I don't really have
any arcs I'm going I have a whole bunch
of art on the circle which arc am I
talking about I kind of need to define
one right I'm so where I've drawn this
on this point right I could have said
well it's got to be on top of the circle
so what if I like started here that's
the law of us point maybe because
remember buying anti-clockwise so I
can't because that here because then
it's going to go on the bottom side
which I daughter do so if I start there
he's are forming an arc like this I do
agree with that and this arc as time
progresses this arc should get longer
and longer and longer until he gets all
the way to enforce me7 now the reason
why this is useful is because this is a
curb leg and that's exactly what is two
meters per second referring to okay how
fast it's going around the edge so in
order to at this while I need to give
this name what do we usually call nicely
let's name this L which means that this
two meters per second constant velocity
i was given before is dl on dt ok so I'm
going to pro se les that's too so this
is where I'm headed this is what I know
so somehow I've got to connect arc
length to this X business right which is
which is where I don't know think think
think for a moment what bridges am I
going to use and I am saying bridges
plural in order to get from something I
know arc length up to X any takers yeah
in between
the angular arcolin so using the phone
okay sure so some in a circle yeah one
of the only things we know about our
claim is you can find the arc length of
a in a circle if you know two things you
need to know the radius which I do
happen to know and what was the other
thing you need to know you need to know
the angle subtended at the center by
your arc yes if you don't r theta well
lucky for you l equals R theta that's
good so I can go from l to feed up right
the arc leg and the people attended the
center they're connected to each other
so I can do some dld theater I can use
chain rule somehow to change the very
water that's good i'm still not there
yeah okay so i'm going to get from l to
thin up using radian measure right and
then i'm going to go from theta 2 x by
taking advantage of fact that this is
not just any circle this is the Unison
right so therefore i have a parametric
representation for this that connects
the angle subtended at the center we
have the x-coordinate namely cos theta
okay so good I've got the I've got the
essay outline mapped out in my head now
I'm ready to actually solve this
question right so here is where I am
going to begin you suggested to me we
should use this l equals R theta
business first okay and that will
connect these two quantities sorry these
two quantities together okay so i'm
going to say l equals R theta provided
that you know let L be the arc leg how
would you describe this thing that like
there I suppose it would be the Arctic
traced out after some number of some
amount of time right so the arc length
traced out by the particle well actually
what do they say what's the word they
use is it a point quaker traced out by
the foot
this variable we've introduced its own
better defined okay so l equals R theta
but of course this is the unit circle so
r is equal to 1 okay cool that's that's
good right now how do we use this either
dl on dt that was given to me in the
question and I want to get to DX on dt
so how am I going to use this and hop
onto my blue alpha theta bridge what am
I going to do you um elevator apparently
are always equal to each other right so
that means when L changes by 1 Thea
should change is watching over right in
other words dl and defeat are with Ella
Thea the same then dl and defeat are
also the same because that makes sense
so therefore if I were to say take this
line and differentiate both sides with
respect to time unless you that gives me
this thing do you see what I'm not
differentiated both sides this is clean
whenever L is changing video is changing
exactly the same rate because in the
division a circle LM data are exactly
the same this is why we love radians
they make working and stuff too so easy
okay so this is handy because I actually
know a deal on dt is right so now i can
say their 4-d theater on dt equals 2
because that's what i was told in the
question about d ln you did so far so
good okay excellent I've used my l 2
theta bridge and now I've got to go from
feeder to X so I need the relationship
between those right so I'm going to say
but what's the relationship between X
and theater we set a port right x equals
2 good i'm going to say x equals cos
theta on the unit sir right like where's
this come from where just like before I
introduced L so I have to define it I
introduce theta so I'm going to define
all you say is the angle at the center I
mean you can't be fancy and you can say
the egg was attended by l4 blah blah
blah blah but if you have a diagram it's
there and this sentence just makes a
career I'm not just plucking this out of
your way okay